chaude
paul quinn pas
trentaine d'entre elles viennent de
créer leur agence et ensemble elles sont
dorénavant pour
taguée factory c'est une agence
artistique donc il n'ya pas seulement
que d un kouign mais on est quand même
la première agence française créée sur
paris spécialisée dans les drag queen we
l'allodynie cdn italia que l'appareil
pourrait comme arabe hostile de rigueur
mais poil de feurs danica diakité
qu'est ce qui est des films aidés
elles sont nombreuses dépositions
grégoire evequoz le fallait soumettre
les concours pour elle
le guépard et la couleur que les eaux à
vous
à bord délire pour une agence comme
factory et c'est quelque chose de toute
façon à toi même aparis un peu plus les
jeunes regardent mais disent rien mais
en province les gens il veut toucher
être regardés parler avec toi pouvoir
que tu es petit et pas une chose et
qu'on peut pas toucher quand c'est un
fait on est des pertes en bout un
secteur les dragsters
les hommes
ses avoirs étaient les vrais vous même
et est loué gogo danseur et drag king
barbus sont les bienvenus